Carrie go Legolas a daughter remembers
the session is reopened so I will
announce the results of the vote the
number of votes 733 a majority of
members that make up the Parliament 374
votes in favor 383
boaty contra votes against 327 a stencil
abstentions 22 one blank vote and on the
basis of these votes the candidate for
the President of the Commission is
proposed by the council and has been
elected by the European Parliament and I
would like to congratulate miss Halle
von der Leyen for her election and I
wish her all the very best for her
mandate and in line with article 1 2 4
para 3 of the rules of procedure I will
inform the council and I will invite
them for the Commission President to
propose the various commissioner
positions and there will be a letter
informing them of the parliaments
decision lacan see and I will give it to
the president who is here
[Applause]
signora for mrs. von der Leyen
I congratulate you on behalf of the
Parliament on your election as president
of the European Commission on behalf of
the other members and the rest of this
assembly you have a very important job
it's very important for the European
institutions we need to prepare for the
hearings of the commissioners the
designate commissioners and you know
that we will be very scrupulous in the
work that we do here in the Parliament
and you mentioned topics today here in
plenary and we look forward to getting
into those in more detail and speaking
to the members of the college with those
and then the competent committees will
be dealing this the next few years are
going to be very important to is
important for the future of the European
Union and we will be successful if there
is close cooperation between the
European institutions I will give you
the floor so that you can speak to the
assembly you have the floor Madame
mr. president and honorable members of
this Parliament I feel so honored and
I'm overwhelmed and I thank you for the
trust you placed in me yet the trust you
placed in me is confidence you placed in
Europe your confidence in a United and a
strong Europe from east to west from
south to north your confidence in a
Europe that is ready to fight for the
future rather than fighting against each
other your confidence in a Europe that
will take the big challenges of our
times together the task ahead of us
humbles me it's a big responsibility and
my work starts now I thank President
Susilo I thank all the group leaders I
thank all the members of parliament who
decided to vote for me today but my
message to all of you is let us work
together constructively because the
endeavor is a united a strong Europe
thank you very much
[Applause]